[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
randall shambly the
lead golf channel analyst and you can
watch each day on golf channel alongside
justin leonard and rich lerner they have
live coverage of the
open championship at royal st george's
golf club
and uh that will continue across all the
nbc platforms golf channel
peacock live coverage second round
currently airing on
golf channel by the way uh brandel
chamblee i believe
picked uh colin morkawa to win the open
championship let me start there
was that your uh pick because that's a
good pick right now well i appreciate
that i i think i'm like
two for 197 picking on wednesday night
since i started picking players but uh
but i appreciate that i'll i'll ride
this wave while i can
this is a guy who's making his debut in
an open championship
and i know he played in the scottish
open i just don't know how much
prep time you need when you play courses
like this brandel uh i mean that that's
pretty quick turnaround to all of a
sudden be playing well
on a golf course like this yeah it used
to be that you needed a lot of prep time
but not anymore i mean they have things
called
google earth and they can sort of plot
out their uh
their misses left and right around a
golf course he doesn't have
misses really he doesn't have big messes
that's for sure and then
you add to the fact that the golf course
is a little softer than it normally
plays so i think that mitigates some of
the experience you might need to have
around there
what is it like though that the the
shots you have to have you have to have
imagination
i would think but yeah right
yeah well typically at an open they the
course goes out and back
so you'll you know you'll have a left to
right wind going out say and then a
right to left
coming back in so you'll need to hold
the ball
into a left to right win and then work
it with the right to left wing so you'll
have to be able to work the ball both
directions this golf course just goes
around in circles
not like all the other seems like
rotation courses but
mostly you have to play shots that are
through different windows you know you
gotta in and colin morkow was talking
about that so
unlike most courses in most weeks on the
pga tour in the united states
you've got to work the ball up and down
left to right right to left so
and and you have the best ball striker
in the world right now leading the event
what happened to phil mickelson
you know really i think that's more
apropos to say
about the pga championship he's only had
he's only had one event all year long
where he was better than i think 21st he
hasn't had a top 20 all year long except
for one week
where he just woke up and played like
phil mickelson when he was uh
25 years old we shot an 80 the first day
well look the worst part about this golf
course is that the rough is really
really thick
and even bryson deshambo earlier in the
week was talking about
the need to find fairways here preston
hasn't talked about the need to find
fairways
since he's been on tour but he said so
this week
phil as we know typically drives it all
over the lot
you get in this rough you cannot recover
well and that brings us to bryson
duchambeau and
he was critical of the uh the driver
not not the person who is the driver of
the driver
but um how surprised were you that
duchambeau threw cobra
under the bus never seen anything like
it
uh ever i mean maybe there's been a time
or two where players had problems with
equipment but you know
those things happen behind closed doors
and they go sort them out but
you know he switched drivers this is not
the driver that he won the us open with
he switched
drivers from when he won the us open and
this is just really poor planning on his
part he should have gone to the event
with seven or eight different heads
where he could have switched him out if
he was having a problem
with this with this new driver and
because of covet restrictions
his whole equipment team couldn't be
there
so you know this is this would be like
you having an off show and blaming it on
the danettes or your producers or
something
uh it was uh it was bizarre i never i
never heard anything like it
if i if i owned that equipment company
you wouldn't be playing my equipment
next week i don't think
wait you're saying not to blame my guys
when we have a bad show
oh okay all right
where where were you a decade ago bryce
um and the one thing that i thought of
with
uh dechambeau was why are you hitting a
driver on this course to begin with
it's not a long it's not a long course
and it's about accuracy
i you know sometimes you have to you
bought into the show
that you've created or that people want
to see if he goes up there with
you know a three iron you know the
gallery is going to be going oh
he doesn't have the driver like is he
bought into hey you came to see me swing
200 miles an hour and my arms may fall
off
yeah hey listen if it is a great point
you know
if he hits iron down there and he can
hit his three iron
almost 300 yards so if he hits iron down
there and he's in the same place as
everybody else
he's still going to have two clubs less
than everybody else into the green
you'll still have the trajectory and
spin rate
so in a lot of aspects from a strategy
standpoint
and from just an equipment structure
standpoint
this is all on him and throw his
equipment company under the bus which by
the way i made some calls yesterday to
equipment companies
talked to various engineers the engineer
at cobra who designs equipment this
fellow by the name of tom olofsky
he's sort of renowned as one of the
smartest if not the smartest
engineer in golf in all of golf
uh so completely through his equipment
company and the engineers
under the bus all that being said
deshambo is great for the sport like he
he does give you
a tune in factor as as as much as
i love jordan spieth he doesn't have the
tune in factor that bryson deshambo does
phil has tuned in how many guys would
you say true
tune in factor that maybe somebody's on
the periphery
of being a golf fan how many how many
golfers
yeah look phil moved the needle
obviously tiger in an unprecedented way
uh but spieth definitely moves the
needle believe it or not he
absolutely in this country moves the
needle rory moves the needle
but bryson is compelling in a lot of
different aspects not only has he done
something
nobody's done incorporate long distance
moves into his golf swing
and then improve his driving in a a
crazy way
he he's messy he makes mistakes he he
yells at reporters and
and cameraman for not protecting his
image uh
he uh he's he's socially awkward in the
media center he wants to tell you how
much he knows
kind of like phil but phil does it in a
funny way and bryson does it in
i don't even know i don't know how you
describe it smug ridiculous
um he makes mistakes all the time off of
the golf balls they're not colossal
mistakes they're
they're clumsy mistakes it's
entertaining as hell
are you team kepca or team deshambo
listen when i thought when kepca was
calling him out on social media and
asking people to go out and heckling
i thought kepca crossed the line i like
kept
i really enjoy listening to him most of
the time i love his golf game
he's james dean to bryson's eddie
haskell
uh i you know bryson is rubbing me
it's tough to it's tough to pull for
bryson when he's acting like this it
really is
by the way spieth was my pick so oh nice
pick
yeah look of all the people on that
leaderboard everybody's got some
weakness almost
almost everybody is dealing with some
weakness he's the one
right now that doesn't really have a
weakness he's driving it
better than he has he's an unbelievable
iron player
and unlike more cow and lose uh like
more cow is not a great putter
louise station is not a great ball
striker spieth is great at everything
i saw where terrell hatton broke his uh
iron on 18. i don't know if it was a
wedge or whatever it was
but he but he he stepped on it a couple
of times and then snapped it
what's the worst meltdown you ever saw
on a golf course
i was playing with a guy once who uh we
were riding a cart
so he had to take you know a handful of
uh clubs over to his
spot where he was chipping this is a
tour player um
and he hit a poor chip and then he took
his wedge and decapitated all the irons
at his feet there were about five or six
of them just like clicking they were all
popping in the air
and like and like in in in a saying we
said like
seven or eight holes left to play you
know he he literally had no iron slipped
after he was done
it was hilarious uh gosh um
you know you i saw a guy well one of my
buddies dudley hart
he uh back when they used to measure how
far you hit it off of the t with the
lines and not meters right so
there was always somebody in the fairway
who would walk off your drive and the
yardage start at 250 whatever and dudley
uh
had one of the worst tempers ever on
tour and so he hits this drive
on a driving hole that hits a tee or
hits a tree right off the tee
and it comes back like 20 yards in front
of us okay
and i wish i could stand up and give you
this but out out
250 yards away is a volunteer with a
clipboard
and he's meant to walk this off so now
he starts taking these exaggerated big
steps
from 250 as if he's going to walk 230
yards back to the thief
right and so he's giving it this you
know with the clipboard
and dudley heart sees him coming and
dudley's just like a volcano ready to
explode
and he just starts screaming at the top
of his lungs
just give me f and 50 yards just give me
evan
you know he's giving it this it was one
of the damn funniest things i've ever
seen didn't rory throw a driver
into the pond one time yeah bay hill one
year uh he threw a three iron into the
pond
you know right out in the middle of his
great throw it was a great throw
and it was on donald trump's golf course
donald
had it fished out and he came up on our
set the next day and gave it to us
any updates on tiger woods no i've heard
nothing
absolutely nothing uh you know i look
i'm like you i mean you call doctors you
ask
you know what what the probability is
him coming back and all of them say the
same thing that it just depends on this
one particular bone and his foot
if it shattered it he's probably done if
it was a clean break he could probably
come back that's all i've heard
and that's just from doctors not from
tigers camp obviously
always great to talk to you uh give my
best to uh justin and uh rich lerner
yeah thank you buddy thanks
always nice talking to you that's uh
brandel chamblee the lead golf channel
analyst he's not afraid always got
strong opinions
coverage of the open championship all
weekend long you got nbc golf channel
peacock
live coverage of the second round
currently going on